Today,
I think I'll compare Portuguese with a
special dialect of Portuguese called
Spanish.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today's topic is how similar or Spanish
and Portuguese,
as you probably know,
Spanish and Portuguese are both Ibero
Romance languages that share a common
origin.
There are different enough that they are
definitely considered different
languages,
but they're also closely related and
quite similar in many ways.
On paper,
the two languages look very similar and
speakers of either language can
generally read the other language
without too much trouble.
The spoken language is however,
are more different from each other and
less mutually intelligible than the
written forms and Portuguese speakers
typically understand spoken Spanish
better than Spanish speakers understand
Portuguese.
Well actually it's mostly because of the
difference in pronunciation between the
two languages,
but we'll get into that a little later.
Spanish and Portuguese share about 89%
lexical similarity,
meaning that 89% of the words have a
cognate or an equivalent in the other
language.
Now,
that doesn't always mean that 89% of the
words will be the same because some of
the different words are very basic and
common words.
And even though cognit words often look
and sound quite similar,
there are other cognates that have
developed quite differently and now
sound and look quite different.
For instance,
this pair of cognates clearly resemble
each other in Spanish moondogs and in
Portuguese and these words mean earth or
world.
Now here's a less obvious pair of
cognates in Spanish and in Portuguese.
By these words mean fish,
it's and you can see the connection but
it's not quite so obvious.
There are some very common everyday
words that are different in the two
languages.
For example,
in Spanish there's European,
so from the verb Ben Sasse and Yo could
ale from the verb gath which both mean I
think these words have cognates in
Portuguese,
but it's also very common to say it wash
from the verb is Sean.
There is a Spanish cognitive,
this word I yet,
but it only means to find,
not to think in Spanish.
There's the verb meet APP meaning to
look at or to watch.
In Portuguese.
The common verbiage is we'll learn.
There is a Portuguese verb meelod but
it's not commonly used.
Personal pronouns.
The personal pronouns in the two
languages are generally similar but with
slightly different forms.
For example,
Yo ill,
no sutras,
no rush,
but also the formal way of saying you is
normally different.
In Spanish it's we'll stead in
Portuguese there's a word velocity but
instead people generally say [inaudible]
and [inaudible] which is like saying sir
or Madam.
These are equivalents of you and
Senorita in Spanish,
but in Spanish they're not used as
pronouns.
False friends.
You will constantly encounter cognates
in Spanish and Portuguese,
but you'll also encounter lots of false
friends.
Words that look and sound the same and
might share a common origin but they're
meaning is actually different and some
of these could potentially cause some
crazy misunderstandings billado.
In Spanish it means skinned or appealed,
but colloquially it also means someone
with a shaved head or a new haircut
glove.
In Portuguese,
it has the same basic meaning of skinned
or peeled,
but in Brazilian Portuguese it also
means naked.
In Portuguese,
the word for octopus is both in Spanish,
the word for octopus is blue book and
buttered will means dust,
but it also means something sexual and
kids don't google it.
In Spanish.
[inaudible] means a delicious dinner.
In Portuguese,
[inaudible] means a weird scene.
And Center is also a slang word for
thing.
So this could mean a weird thing.
It'll be now in Spanish means tip like a
tip for a waiter.
[inaudible] means tuition fees like for
university and in Brazilian Portuguese
it means bribe.
So even though lots of words are pretty
much the same in either language,
it might be a little dangerous to assume
that they mean the same thing.
Pronunciation.
The main reason that the spoken forms of
the two languages are less intelligible
than the written forms is because they
differ significantly in phonology.
Portuguese has much more complex
phonology than Spanish with many extra
sounds,
and this is one reason that Portuguese
speakers have an easier time
understanding spoken Spanish.
Then vice versa.
Consonants in Spanish.
The B,
D and g consonants have soft
pronunciations that occur,
for example,
between vowels.
The way those soft sounds work is
different.
In Portuguese,
European,
Portuguese has the soft d sound,
while some Brazilian accents don't.
For example,
in Spanish,
Nether in Portuguese mother and in
Brazilian Portuguese,
Portuguese doesn't have the soft be in
Spanish in Portuguese,
severe.
Next,
the rolled our sound of Spanish
corresponds to a rather different sound
in Portuguese when it's at the beginning
of a word or if it's doubled in Spanish.
Could that be though in Portuguese?
Xapi in Spanish,
in Portuguese too.
Next,
the sound represented by a double l in
Spanish has a corresponding sound in
Portuguese represented by l h for
example.
In Spanish there's and in Portuguese
there's phenomenal meaning fail and
Portuguese has some consonants that
don't have an equivalent in Spanish.
First a shutter sound,
it's spelled with c h or with x,
so in Spanish we have yellow,
but in Portuguese chigga meaning arrives
[inaudible] sound.
In Spanish we have,
I couldn't see it,
and in Portuguese we have as you can see
it.
This is another example of a difference
in soft consonants.
In both languages.
The letter g represents a soft g sound
rather than a go when it's followed by
an e or an I.
But the soft sound is different in
either language.
Listen,
again,
I can see here there's this year next a
va sound Spanish doesn't really have a v
sound.
It does have the soft be,
which kind of sounds similar to a v,
but Portuguese has a distinct v sound.
So in Spanish we have BC and in
Portuguese we have visitor.
In Spanish we have Leonardo,
and in Portuguese we have leave and one
more a z sound.
The sound is not found in many Spanish
words,
but in Portuguese it's very common.
So in Spanish we have,
but at Csun and in Portuguese we have
pcs.
This sound is often found between vowels
and at the beginning of words,
vowels.
There are quite a few more vowel sounds
in Portuguese than there are in Spanish.
Spanish has five pure vowels.
While Portuguese has all of those plus
seven additional ones.
Spanish has just one e sound,
which sounds like a Portuguese has this
and an additional one like the f inset
in Portuguese.
It's difficult to predict which one to
use in any given word.
But these ones are different in Spanish,
in Portuguese mirror,
but these ones are the same in Spanish
Messa and in Portuguese Miza.
When a word has the diphthong ea in
Spanish,
it usually corresponds to an open e in
Portuguese for example,
in Spanish.
See it there.
And in Portuguese said Spanish also has
just one,
oh,
sounds like in the word go,
but shorter.
But Portuguese has an additional open,
oh,
which sounds like the o and pot in
Spanish.
A bill in Portuguese or view.
And sometimes the diphthong were in
Spanish corresponds to the open.
Oh,
in Portuguese.
So in Spanish we have escuela and in
Portuguese we have scholar.
Now these might not seem like major
differences so far,
but there are lots of differences like
that.
Reduced vowels,
vowels in Spanish are quite clearly
pronounced in their full form,
but vowels in Portuguese often become
reduced,
especially when they are unstressed at
the end of a word.
So in Spanish we have Gasa,
but in Portuguese we have Casa.
In Spanish we have it.
And in Portuguese we have,
in Spanish we have Audi,
which means it opens and in Portuguese
we have nasal vowels.
Portuguese also has five nasal vowels
that don't occur in Spanish.
I nasal vowel means that some air is
released through your nose,
which creates a distinct sound.
Vowels become nasal [inaudible] when
they are followed by a nasal consonant
and Emma or an n in Spanish and data and
in Portuguese,
in Spanish,
in Suunto and in Portuguese.
This also happens when there is a Tilda
over a vowel like in this Portuguese
word,
Itamar meaning sister.
Because of the extra vowels in
Portuguese,
there are also more diphthongs meaning
two vowels that blend together in one
syllable.
This includes some nasal diphthongs.
For example,
in Spanish we have six cm,
but in Portuguese it's six sound.
In Spanish we have limonus and in
Portuguese Lee Moreish.
Little differences like these add up to
make Portuguese and Spanish sound rather
different grammar.
Spanish and Portuguese grammar are
generally very similar,
but they do have numerous differences as
well.
Gender,
both languages basically have two
genders,
masculine and feminine,
but sometimes the gender of cognitive
words is different.
For example,
words in Spanish ending with our
masculine and their equivalents in
Portuguese ending in honoring our
feminine.
So in Spanish we have and we actually,
which is masculine,
but in Portuguese we have [inaudible],
which is feminine.
Both languages have for definite
articles for the two genders and
singular and plural.
But notice that Spanish also has the
neuter singular definite article.
It's not used with nouns,
but with adjectives or possessive
pronouns in order to use them like nouns
for example.
[inaudible] which means the important
thing is love.
In Portuguese it would be,
we pretend they were more with all being
the masculine,
singular,
definite article verbs.
The way verb tenses work in the two
languages is very similar.
Almost all verb tenses have an exact
equivalent in the other language just
with slightly different conjugations.
So in Spanish we have no sodas,
common,
most best color,
which means we eat fish and in
Portuguese that would be nauseous.
[inaudible] saw the present tense form
is the same and next to pass 10 sentence
in Spanish,
a bias commit.
On best callow they ate fish and in
Portuguese eels middle by.
In this case,
the conjugations aren't exactly the
same,
but they are equivalent.
Now a future sentence in Spanish,
Yoko made episcopal,
which means I will eat fish and in
Portuguese it's it will come right page,
but without any context given for the
simple future tense here,
this might sound kind of stiff and
people often use the going to future
form.
Instead.
In Portuguese it would be ill for middle
based and it's Spanish.
It would be,
Yup.
Boy,
yeah.
Metaphase Pescara.
One difference in the verb system is
that the perfect tense is formed with
the different auxiliary verb,
Spanish uses and then as the auxiliary
verb,
which means to have but only as an
auxiliary verb.
The main verb for to have in Spanish is
Denette.
Portuguese has a verb or veal,
but instead the verb did is used as the
auxiliary verb,
which means to have tish is a cognate of
Spanish.
Dennis in Spanish we have a laser liver,
which means I have read the book and in
Portuguese we have bill.
Thank you.
Leave Lever,
which means I have been reading the
book.
So notice that the auxiliary verbs are
different.
And notice that the past participle of
the verb,
meaning reed,
is almost the same,
but more importantly,
note that this type of sentence means
something different than either
language.
In Spanish it means I have read the book
in Portuguese it means I have been
reading the book.
In other words,
the past action is still continuing in
order to say,
I have read the book in Portuguese,
you would use the present tense instead
like this,
the only leave,
I believe that Latin American Spanish is
more like Portuguese in this regard,
and that difference is only in the
present.
Perfect.
The past perfect doesn't have that kind
of difference.
So if we want to express,
they had read the book.
In Spanish we would say ibm laser liver,
and in Portuguese we would say
[inaudible] believe the main difference
between these two is just the auxiliary
verb.
We'd order.
The word order is generally quite
similar between the two languages as
you've probably noticed already,
but there are some differences too in
yes or no questions.
In Spanish,
the subject can come either before or
after the verb.
Like this.
I've lay gang lists or a gambling lists,
but in Portuguese it must come before
the verb,
like this lfl English,
the placement of object pronouns in
Spanish,
the object Pronoun normally comes before
the verb for example.
And Mia you though,
which means he helped me in Portuguese,
it comes after the verb,
like this,
Il [inaudible] another example in
Spanish,
maybe that's how you that.
Okay,
which means are you going to help me or
what?
And in Portuguese [inaudible] or visors
d'adamo cave.
Actually the location of the Pronoun in
the first sentence is something that
comes from Brazilian Portuguese,
but at sometimes used in Portugal too
because of the influence of Brazilian
Portuguese through Brazilian tv shows
and the like.
Some people consider the second sentence
to be more proper in European Portuguese
contractions with prepositions in
Spanish prepositions mostly function as
individual units with just these
exceptions.
The preposition that plus the definite
article l becomes Dell meaning from
that,
the preposition plus l becomes added
meaning to the,
there are just those two in Spanish,
but in Portuguese prepositions form all
sorts of contractions.
So in Spanish we have an [inaudible],
which means in the book,
but in Portuguese we have new leaf.
In Spanish we have,
they will not send Yoda,
which means from a lady,
but in Portuguese we have Duma,
slaughter it,
Spanish.
We have the Aqi meaning from here,
but in Portuguese we have the Geek.
These mean Portuguese is a sister
language of Spanish in Spanish and in
Portuguese,
[inaudible] word for word ets.
Portuguese is ah,
language,
sister of the Spanish.
These sentences consistent tiredly of
cognates and have identical grammar.
The main difference is the different
definite articles and the words for
sister take a somewhat different form
and Amana,
eat,
emote.
This pair of words is a good example of
how Spanish and Portuguese cognates can
sometimes look and sound quite
different.
Let's look at one more sentence and see
what we find.
These mean very few countries in the
world take pride in having so many
different styles of music and dance in
Spanish.
Mig,
Bogo,
spices and Amanda [inaudible] word for
word.
It's very few countries in the world are
proud of having so many styles,
different of music and dance.
And then there's the Portuguese sentence
went to Portuguese removed store of
yours.
10 stills,
the [inaudible] word for word.
Very few countries in the world are
proud of having so many styles,
different of music and dance.
Again,
these sentences are similar,
but there are a few differences.
The way of expressing very few,
it's slightly different,
but the words are cognates.
Next,
notice that in Portuguese,
the preposition and definite article
contract together into one word while in
Spanish they're separate words.
Next we see the verb corresponding to to
be in each language.
Is that in Spanish and also she taught
him in Portuguese.
They are both conjugated in the third
person,
plural.
Present tense,
but you can see that the conjugated
forms are different in either language.
Next,
the words here are a bit different.
The Spanish word is an infinitive form.
While the Portuguese is a personal
infinitive.
The infinitive by itself is,
and also notice that the word for dance
is different,
but also notice that it sounds like the
English word ballet by Lee.
Hmm.
There's also a cognate word in
Portuguese bile,
but in Portuguese it refers to an event
like a ball or a prom,
and in Spanish there's also the word
done Fao,
which refers to a specific types of
artistic dance as opposed to dancing in
general.
Very often there are possible cognates
for every word in a sentence,
but they sometimes have a somewhat
different usage or frequency of use in
either language.
In these two similar sentences,
we see how similar the two languages can
be with the biggest difference,
simply lying in pronunciation,
but things are often said more
differently.
For example,
a somewhat more natural sentence in
Portuguese might be more into
[inaudible],
tench steels,
differential killers in this variation
rather than to be plus an adjective.
Here we have Ken plus the infinitive of
a verb,
meaning to be proud.
So as you can see,
Spanish and Portuguese are indeed sister
languages that have a lot in common.
They do have a lot of little differences
that altogether and make them distinct
languages.
But knowing either language would
definitely help you learn the other one
relatively quickly.
So the question of the day for speakers
of either Spanish or Portuguese who have
studied the other language,
did you find it easy to learn what was
easy and what was challenging?
Also,
feel free to share other examples of
their similarities and differences in
the comments down below.
Be sure to subscribe to this channel and
also checkout lane.
Focus on facebook,
twitter,
and instagram.
And a big special thanks to all of my
patrion supporters,
especially these magnificent people
right here on the screen for their
monthly pledges.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.
Okay.